[Música]
desesperado apenas com o seu tiro para salvar
várias vezes de um 4 nada e algumas equipes
olhar muito bem as coisas aparecem com
o pássaro e não há nada para mover ou
mover tudo e o de separar sobe
ou muito mais 5
chachi que estávamos saindo de lietor e tal
a pista de dança é cara e
Guayas e prepare e eu vou pedir aminatu
um rosto bem agir rosto e eu desde
ande seu rosto
venha na sua cara
e oferece atos de caminhada na rua e uma chifa
liquidado
se você sair por causa disso já aconteceu
ao chegar em bogotá
e você país
Oh
[Música]
mercado de ações de xangai
no seu túmulo do meu celular
vou esperar que pena sua vida voce
você será
oh
e às vezes apenas o seu rosto
venha na sua cara
e que te acorrentam cara a cara
desesperado acabar com você para enfrentar
rainha você enfrentar nada aconteceu tarde
rainha age cara sempre
chachi se não pastorita
a pensão motiva aumentos são caros
sempre vá para luis freg aminatu a
cara de pena do seu engasgo
e às vezes só você para enfrentar
venha na sua cara
[Música]
Como certamente estamos indo para o palácio
sinfonia externa total ativa tem
civilidade que caiu luz 16h e
aguçar um canal dele é aqui no
chefe de equipe ninguém escreveu primeiro
um inquieto desde botas gabriel ducado
bay e facebook e um canal de ajuda
do inglês cristão eles se aplicam ao rosto
desde a remoção e trabalho maravilhoso
willis
aqui se eles escrevem um canal para perder